Well,
I won't
back down,
you can stand up at the gates of hell,
but I won't.
In the first video I posted this
morning,
I read a letter from a variety of
student activist groups calling for my
silencing apology and discipline.
In this video,
I'm going to read a similar letter from
a branch of the Canadian Union of public
employees asking for similar measures.
And so this is the second letter.
This is from the Canadian Union of
public employees.
Actually,
it's from one branch of the Canadian
Union of public employees.
Um,
I should also note that another
president of the Canadian Union of
public employees actually came and
talked to me yesterday on,
on something unrelated to this about his
fear that the new university sexual
harassment policy is so broad and so
wide that it risks,
uh,
turning normal misunderstandings into
career destroying a debacle.
And so,
so I'm just telling you that so that you
know that,
you know,
there's not homogeneity on the left and,
and there's not homogenous eat within
the Canadian Union public employees
either.
But anyways,
here's what they want.
Jordan Peterson's comments.
Make the U of t a hostile place to work
and study as queer people who study and
work at the University of Toronto.
We have the right to fully access all
the resources of the university without
fear.
We have the right to enter and
participate in every classroom,
every lab,
library,
athletic facility,
in event space,
and we have the right to participate as
ourselves.
We have the right to go to work and be
treated with dignity and respect.
We know no one and explanation of much
less a defense of our gender or
sexuality.
We sit insist on a truth,
so simple that it shouldn't need to be
stated that we have not.
Psychology professor has who has never
met us are the authorities on our own
identities and yes,
we have the right to be recognized and
referred to as we are in the ways we
choose reviews to low.
Anyone.
Least of all,
someone who could be our professor or
our work supervisor to the side that he
knows better who we are and what is the
right way to refer to us.
If insisting on this kind of recognition
seems petty or an unimportant to som,
we remind them of our long and
continuing struggle as queer people to
gain the same rights,
freedoms and recognitions enjoyed by CIS
straight people.
CIS.
That's a word I really don't like.
By the way we remind that's manufactured
word and that's exactly the kind of word
that I not ever going to be compelled to
say.
We remind them that for us going to work
already involves daily Calculus,
situation by situation,
colleague by calling of what and how
much of ourselves to reveal.
We have to remain conscious of all at
all times of the details of our lives
that may make us physically unsafe.
Prompt,
humiliating questions lead to social
alienation or takeaway our chance next
employment contract we desperately need
in this city in 2016.
It is not safe to be a queer person.
That's why we had a month long pride
festival last year and it is especially
safe to be a trans or gender
nonconforming person at the University
of Toronto.
Our commitment must not only be to
protect,
but to affirm and elevate our colleagues
who faced discrimination in danger in
their daily lives.
We should be proactive in inviting,
recognizing that the default expectation
for queer people is that we will not be
welcomed in new environments.
We entered and stand reason comments by
professor Jordan Peterson have
communicated that in some parts of our
working lives,
trans and gender nonconforming people
are not welcome,
that will be denied basic recognition of
our humanity,
that we will be called delusional and
lectured to and that a potential
supervisor will be given authority to
decide who we really are and how we
should be referred to at work in our
unions will view this situation
constitutes a clear and unacceptable
violation of our human rights and our
workplace rights.
It has also a violation of the
collective agreements we negotiate with
the university to set the terms and
expectations of our working lives.
These collective agreements guarantee US
protection from quote verbal conduct or
other forms of communication that
emphasize the sex,
sexuality or gender identity or
expression of an employee in a manner
that the actor,
uh,
he Jordan Peterson knows or ought
reasonably to know,
is unwelcome or creates an intimidating,
hostile or offensive working or learning
environment.
Professor Peterson ought reasonably to
know that refusing to his dress,
his students and his tds as they request
to be addressed and deriding their
identities in public by.
I have no idea what,
what that means is unwelcome behavior
that makes his classroom,
his department and his university
intimidating,
hostile or offensive for us.
The UFT administration ought reasonably
to know that when comments are made
public,
they need to be swiftly and
categorically condemned and appropriate
actions need to be taken to restore a
workplace free of intimidation and
hostility.
But in case any of our managers and
supervisors didn't understand that
actions like professor Peterson's and
the silence of the university
administration in response are
unwelcomed,
hostile and offensive.
Let us be the ones to tell you they are.
And now you know,
we expect and demand better and our
union will be organizing and acting
accordingly.
Sincerely,
qp three,
nine,
zero.
Two Queer Caucus,
Canadian Union of public employees.
Local three nine.
Oh,
two.
So if you're looking for something to do
to help you could write a letter to the
individuals whose emails I have posted
in the information box and the
description box that that is associated
with this video.
So email them and email all of them and
send me a copy if you want.
That would be helpful.
Be particularly useful if it came from
students.
Thanks very much.
Bye.